to 13 any alterations
additions
counselors let me know
i thought there was might have been a
might have been so um
your counselor becky moves these um
acceptance of these minutes as a true
and correct record of
june the 11th meeting and seconded by
councillor williams
um any alterations no all those in favor
these
minutes be accepted please say aye
against
declare it carried matters arising item
four yep um
the updates on the nitrate studies we
mentioned at the last meeting are we
likely to get an update on that at some
stage
uh it well there was an update to the um
zone community so it'll it was
did he give it tim davey gave it is it
minuted
the el nino yeah i think so okay um so
well i don't know
we'll have to check can it be really
good sophie if that could be circulated
to us
just the that was one of particular
interest thank you
yes tim
no this was yes it was the one about
the wells um the high nitrates on the
the
um wells uh sort of north of um
uh yeah north of christchurch in our
patch
that we're showing that rise and yes
just a reminder councillors need to use
the microphones for
recording thank you any other
any other updates sorry any other
matters arising
no i was just
looking myself no that's all right um
all right um we don't move in second
rising do we or do we perhaps we don't
all right thank you um item five
no deputations or presentations and so
let's move
to um uh item six
uh which is a planting proposal for
fernside springs these are
headwater springs for the southbrook
stream on pinevale farm
and pass over to our water environment
advisor sophie allen to take us through
the report
thank you kirakoto so
pine belle farm er is in firm site as
sandra explained it is part of the south
brook catchment which flows into the cam
and has been considered as part of the
camp river enhancement fund
uh i think back in 2018 there was a
an allocation of funding by the canberra
enhancement fund subcommittee
uh which included consultation with doc
and
north canterbury fish and game were
present at that meeting
and gave their approval of that
allocation of funding
so 33 000 was allocated to fernstein
springs at that stage we thought
initially it works would be
we scoped out larger amounts of works
than what is proposed here
and that didn't include fencing things
have changed since then where
fencing is now required under plane
change seven
for cattle and so it's something that
we're not considering to fund
but planting is something that we can
fund at the site
so it's uh we are still looking at
potentially allocating that full amount
but doing it in a staged approach where
we work with the landowner to to make
sure things are going well
where they're very fenced off you know
they haven't got around to fencing off a
couple other spring kids
so it's a bit of an encouragement for
them to do the right thing
and they they are
working with us now
it's been a long discussion as you might
know um but it seems to be working
towards a positive um outcome where they
are putting in the fencing and uh are
looking at
committing to the maintenance post the
two years where
we have initially looked after the
plants during the early stages
uh so i'm happy to take questions about
um how this might work it is something
that we
we have been doing sediment traps for
example and on um
which is probably more of a community
benefit but we haven't done
looked at private planting planting on
private land
is for the camera enhancement fund so
just keen to get your feedback on that
in particular
just the um
what checks and measures will we have on
the on the maintenance
yeah so we've got the first two years of
maintenance
uh by us but also by contractor on
behalf of wdc
so that is should be enough for these
these particular species we're looking
at that should be enough sometimes for
other species you might need three years
but these are quite fast growing wetland
plants
so two years should be sufficient we
have made clear
with both elysee and landowner that the
maintenance will be their responsibility
after that period
it's something that we could get into
we're looking at getting a letter signed
letter agreement
it's not something that can be easily
enforced however because environment
canterbury have such agreements with
people for immediate steps funding and
for example if the land is sold
unless you have something on the title
it's not something you can enforce
or for example with stock damage there
have been cases
where you know that's a very difficult
discussion and it's hard to guarantee
if stock to get in that that the
landowner would
would replace the plants we can what we
could insist is is that the
fencing uh scientists raised that
there's only two wires and one of one of
the sides
that got um so one of the new fencing
has four wires but some of the fencing
that was already in has only got two
wires so we can insist that they've
upgraded that to at least three with an
outrigger or four wires
before the plants went in you might like
there's four pictures here
of the lehman's road which is a larger
planning proposal can we just flick
through them i took these so
um uh that's that's the the spring
head which is on your page 16.
that's this bit here this
it's here looking from lehman's road
here
up the string that's that bit there and
there's 200 meters along the road
so so you can see the four wires
on the side on the road uh sorry uh and
then there's yeah
yeah which he hasn't you know that's an
existing boundary fence
and the the actual new fencing is
is going away from you in a parallel
direction
um oh sorry in a right angle to the
photo
and that's um that's naturally
regenerated
um wetland plants that's this flow of
the spring coming
down towards the roadside so we're not
looking
up and then yeah yeah that's the corner
that
yeah so we're not looking at planting
anything in here that's like so i
understand it's already
native vegetation but just further along
this side here
that's where we'll be putting in similar
sort of plants nothing too
too high i mean potentially this could
have been kakatiya in the past but we're
not looking at putting in kakatiya trees
straight away we're looking at putting
in russia's reeds grasses that
in the future you know you could put
some more trees in but i think in terms
of for the for the farmers they
they um we were saying we're not putting
any any big trees in
yep oh councillor williams
and it looks like it's electric fence a
two-way electric fence which stocks
going to go through that
um quite regular in that type of fence
because they do
um particularly getting down into water
in areas
um i think it needs to be a bit more
substantial fence to keep animals
out otherwise we're going to plant and
a month later there's going to be no
plants left
so if we don't get a substantial enough
fence
you know i don't know how you um what
what have you got
organised to make sure there's a stock
proof fence long term yeah so one of the
issues is that
stock exclusion does qualify one
hot wire does count as stock exclusion
currently so we would be going above
what's considered stock exclusion uh i i
agree that we could
yeah we should be saying you know two
wires is
there's a potential we have seen in the
past that stock have gotten like it is
just cattle it's not sheep just to be
clear
but kettle can still get through two
wires particularly if the ground is
irregular so that there are some maybe
some hollows or places where
so we could say that uh the minimum we
will be looking at is three wires
as a suggestion with all the hot wire
uh councilman so are those hot wires
that we're
going to stipulate with the um two or
three wires
because yeah what they do is they stick
their heads through the fence
and if anything's going to be if there's
only one wire that's going to be hot it
should be the bottom one
but um yeah i've seen calves get in
through
into these plantings and just decimate
them on farms that i've been on
but my question is actually about the
you're saying the trees and whatnot and
i did notice in the report that they
that um he didn't want trees planted
along the roadside but um and i would
i fully agree with that but i think that
the um
is that along the entire road or just by
the intersections because i know it's
very problematic with the um for inside
john's road plasket
intersection um with regard to
visibility
but i can see like on on these um
like on that photo that
you know as long as it's not too close
to the intersection where you've got
visibility
um you could probably get away with
planting a few taller species
further up the road yes we could
plant further up i haven't proposed that
in this because of the
focus on on filtrating felting filtering
out farm nutrients
as so there is quite a generous road
swale
and so i'm with you know with long grass
and there are some existing trees that
are not native but
um they might be providing some habitat
for
for you know the waterway there so i'm
saying that's efficient and we should be
focusing on the farm side on that in
that spring
council um
hot topic at my place at the moment
seeing my cattle have broken through
fences like that three
times in the last fortnight two-wire hot
wire is completely inadequate when we're
spending
14 grand you've only got to get a power
cut and you're defenseless and the
cattle will work it out in 15 minutes if
there's no juice in the
in the thing you've got to have a proper
fence there probably
nothing um cyclone netting is cheaper
than and probably better than
a four or five wire fence um i would go
so fast to say if we're not fencing that
properly
with with a five four to five wire or
anything we shouldn't be doing it at all
because they will go they'll go through
those through
through to our hot wire and i mean
the fences now i've got are uh one point
two netting
and the titan and a hot wire on top of
that and that
pretty much keeps them out if they even
if the power goes down
but an ordinary fence they'll they'll i
mean they can jump it if they want to
you've got to have one one hot wire
without riggers or on
or on top as you know um or you've got
to have um
a cyclone but it's a two-wire hot wire
like that there's only good
well the power's there it's not even
good while the power's there they want
to go through they
as nikki said they put a head and
shoulders through and if they get a belt
they jerk forwards often instead of back
and they're through just like that
so and and if in the winter when their
coats are long the
thing doesn't give them enough belt
through the long hair either so
no you've got to fence it properly or
don't do it
i
i think that's a bungee fence um
potentially for
your access just for just like i think
just that buddy there yeah
it might be um sorry it might be too
that photo there is from the
from the corner of fernside and lehman's
so the fence is actually
you can just see the the that's the
stream
you can just see yes this is back at the
corner you can just see the fence post
um through the course um on your
there yeah that's the that's the
professor there's another shot
if you want to flip through to another
one yeah that's right at the corner
that's the strainer post and you can see
the fencing
um uh there along there you can just see
a bit of wire
yes that's that's where you have uh the
four wires that have gone in so
yeah and that goes along you can see
that
where we were looking at on the first
shot the spring is
is um at right angles uh to the road
further way further down uh councillor
williams oh sorry yes no
councillor before you better go yeah
thank you
um sophie i really like the fact that
this is visible
and that fence a very popular road
obviously
um but obviously i don't know all the
history of all the springs that feed
into the camp
catchment are there other areas that are
going to
want funding to do the same thing at the
springs
um and how was this one in particular
selected
yes so definitely there are lots of
springs uh even potentially this owner
has other springs that are on
a different part of the property that
could be fenced off
i don't know the history of why these
particular springs
were were selected it could be that yes
the visibility
um but this was before my time so maybe
sandra could elaborate
yeah well if you want me yes this goes
back
um yeah yes
okay and i think this
come to the table you have to talk to us
otherwise the public can't hear you
i think this does tie in with our
overall work that's been done on the cam
catchment and
dating back to henry hudson report of
about 2016
i believe so that actually even though
that was focused on
the uh enhancement fund and how that
gets
allocated that was very much okay well
where are the hot spots across
our district and it was looking at a
range of different things from
sediment traps to you know wetlands
uh into spring heads like this
and there are a number of others in the
cam river catchment
over by five crossroads as well at the
head of to a hilly stream there's a
number of
spring heads there that have been
identified for protection as well
um so that's where it's originated from
and that whole process had identified
that the top areas that you could spend
the
enhancement fund on i'm sure though if
you went around the
camera of a catchment you would actually
find a lot of other areas
that um you could actually say have
uh equal potentially even higher
priorities
um so but i would actually say that
these projects
um are part of getting the ball rolling
you know we need to be um
starting to spend some of the fun um it
has been a long time coming
and a lot of work has gone in uh getting
our consent in place which should
hopefully be imminent
will be enabler to getting some of this
um these works done
uh and in the future i think there'll be
other areas within the camera of a
catchment that we're identifying and
coming back with
whether it's part of the zipper funding
we've got um
to actually look at improving other area
areas within the catchment
so it's there has been some work done
that
um to distill it into priority areas
so i think you can have confidence as
elected members that there's some
thought and logic behind
why this is being promoted but at the
same time
i'm sure you will find and people will
be aware of other
um high hot spots within the catchment
that also need to be addressed
um well i can this does go back
to about 2000 when
it was identified before we got the
hudson report in its final version way
back in
our pre about 2007
this was a particularly hot spot there's
a major
spring on the property by the gum tree
which
and then the gum tree it rises there
goes along the roadside and then turns
the corner down there
so this was identified as and there were
cows in it all the time now the
landowners now and it's only in the last
few months
through um implementation of a farm
environment plan that he's done the
fencing
so there was also an application from
the original
the landowner here um we've got two
parties we've got the landowner
cathy van beek and we've got mark hurst
who is the
um the sheer milker
they kathy had originally applied to the
fund before it
when it was administered by staff to do
some fencing
and um and provide
funding for a reticulated water supply
so they weren't going into the spring
so there's a long history of it and
the um the legislation and the
plan changes have forced the landowner
to
up the ante and do some of the stuff
that we originally
proposed to to offer to them um
and that they weren't forthcoming in the
in the initial stages
but now um we have stepped back
and basically enhancing the fencing
um that they've been required to provide
with
planting so that to reduce the nutrient
runoff this is a
as i said you just need to stop up there
and see
a major it's a major spring head um
which would be um well to protect
uh and i agree with all the questions
that have come up we do need to
ensure i'm going over my brief here but
we do need to ensure that
the fencing is is immaculate because
i've i've got i mean
i complain about this farm because the
kettle the cows get into the stream
and so sandra just just going back to my
question the question is that if people
see this and it's
been provided plantings from the public
purse um
the question could be asked why not my
farm
so how are we going to answer that and
and what was the strategy used to
determine that this
farm as opposed to others should get the
funding
and that's probably a question for
probably kelly actually
i i think it's a goo it's a good
question
um i think if we're looking forward um
uh kelly's going to be able to better um
than me answer looking back why this one
was established as opposed to others
um but if you're looking forward there
are um
there is a presentation coming up around
uh funding in the future um
and for biodiversity funding um which
people may have access to in certain
areas for
significant natural areas etc where um
if people are coming to us and saying
what about my spring what about my farm
we will be in a better position
hopefully to be able to say look well
you know your farm's great and we're
happy to work with you and these are all
the things that we can do to actually
enable you to get some funding which is
public funding to be able to do stuff on
your farm as well
so this one's mainly because it's been
worked on for a long time i would say so
and it's further along than some of the
others and it is
quite similar and it's a significant
area okay just just wanting to be able
to justify it too
yes well fair enough um counsellor
atkinson and i think that's the question
is it defendable
that's that's that's the real question
because if it's defendable there's
in my mind there's no question but if
there's if it's not defendable
then we are going to be challenged on it
yeah just the two points i would add to
that
is that part
what i was responding to before is that
part of this is actually to get the ball
rolling
so we're not coming to you and saying
this is the
highest priority within the catchment
um so i think this does fall into the
category of
it needs momentum we do need to do
something and this is an area that has
been identified to get
um it rolling um the other point i would
make is
like if we do end up in the situation of
people coming back to us
and saying we've seen what you've done
here
why why aren't you doing something on my
property you could potentially argue
we've actually achieved something in
terms of people getting to think about
what we're doing so um it's not
necessarily a bad thing
thank you any more questions councillor
williams
next question um is about the course
um because there's no animals in the now
the course is going to overrun
the plantings because that's what
happens is that going to be removed
so it's not something that our council
would be in charge of removal
um it's it is a i think it's listed
under the
regional peace management as a boundary
plant where you do
you know the landowner has a
responsibility for it now and and will
continue to have that responsibility
it won't disturb the plantings i mean
the plantings can grow up around it but
it's not something that we're going to
take responsibility to remove
and if they don't then um you know i
have said you know you know this
there'll be weeds that will come up that
will be your responsibility in the
future
it's just a gun dirt the enhancement
looking for those things be important
but you don't want
heaps of old gorse bushes around um
ruining that look as well with us all i
think it's gonna be a common theme with
uh stock exclusion coming in that we're
going to see lots of margins some will
look amazing and some will
but in terms of the species mean and
insects
will love the gorse and uh birds will
love the ghosts and you know they're the
skinks probably you know they're it's
still a useful plant
in terms of biodiversity so it's just um
it does does spread on agricultural land
so it's more of more of an agricultural
piece than a biodiversity pest
yeah councilman just with regards to
that course are we
taking the view with the course that it
um of
it as a nursery plant because it's it's
well known to be
something that is good to have in place
to to um
enable the establishment of the natives
underneath and then it gets removed
there's also a nitrogen fixing plant
though so it does leach nitrate
um into waterways if you get it in quite
a high density you could be
creating a source of nitrate so pros and
cons
so if we could would we advocate for its
removal fryer too
to start with a few isolated plants i
wouldn't say they'll be a significant
source so i wouldn't justify it for that
reason
um if if you think that it's important
for for the visibility of the of the
project and what
and the impression and that's that's the
decision we can try
not just visibility but also the fact
that it's well known that the viability
of gore seed it
extends over 30 to 50 years so any one
of those
seeds from those flowers on those bushes
will be good for
ever so if it's something that we do
want to see less of then maybe we should
start with a clean slate and just give
the idea that it shouldn't be there but
if if we're taking the
point of view that it's a nursery plant
just to enable the establishment of the
preferred species then
you know that's another attack really
in this situation of course wouldn't be
necessary for establishment i mean
you're probably on very harsh windy
sights uh with
you know very dry that's where you want
that nursery plant but uh here
it wouldn't be yeah so removal wouldn't
be an issue but uh it's just whether we
as a council want to you know when i go
back to the landowner and
and the leasi and say this is these are
conditions um
upgrade the fencing uh signed agreement
uh of course remember just that
negotiation might it might get harder
and harder to
to get traction i think what they're
getting from us particularly this this
project they're actually getting a
significant
um donation towards this if you will and
um you know at a couple hours with the
digger
and that would be done invested really
quickly and then they could start with a
good clean slate
um i if i'm not wrong um
are not farmers supposed to control and
actually
they're supposed to remove within um is
it five
ten meters of a boundary right now i've
seen a lot of course fences get pulled
out
in in the last couple years so that's
just remnants of
something that should have been taken
care of but
no that was actually well that was
actually my question one of the
requirements and my understanding is
that it's supposed to be removed so if
we don't start with the requirements
then we're starting on a bad foot
so i mean if the requirements are that
it's supposed to be removed within 10
meters of the boundary
then that's what should happen because
we're asking them to do some stuff here
that
around starting on the slate and where
we want to finish
and and i absolutely agree with kelly
about you know let's start somewhere and
get going you know
but it needs to be around if there are
requirements here you have to do i think
we should follow them
that's the williams that
property is it owned by kathy van beek
so she's the owner of it but she's
leasing it to a farmer so
who would be required the owner or the
leasi to do
this work and who would be responsible
the owner or the leasee
so i have discussed it with elisee that
he has been a long-term legacy from my
understanding and
kathy has said you know talk to mark
about these things
and he has agreed that it is his job to
to maintain
things such as course under control
but whether you know we we can't
uh we will have we won't have that
ability to to enforce this
and i don't believe i think it's more of
a regional council issue to enforce the
regional peace management plan
oh sorry mr we don't you're right we
don't have the ability to enforce it
because it's environment canterbury who
can enforce um
course on the boundaries and look we get
them on council and we get little
letters from environment kennedy asking
us to clear the course on our boundaries
sometimes as well which is a little
embarrassing but um
it does happen at times um so look
environment can we can definitely
enforce it and
um could um are we able to the money
which is primarily for planting
if the people on the farm have an issue
with clearing the course themselves
they're not going to have an issue with
the course being gone of course
but an issue with the resource to be
able to actually remove the course are
we able to use
any of the funding that we have for
planting to be able to remove the gauss
before we actually put the planting in
noting that the gauss which is
identified there if you were just going
to cut
and poison that it would be very cheap
and and not very labor intensive to do
because it's not a a very big area
there's only a few a few bushes here so
yeah we do have additional funds that
uh the the from understand the camera
river enhancement fund isn't tied to i
mean if we wanted to we could fund
um fencing out of it and i think a
fencing upgrade is something we can
definitely fund because as i mentioned
just one hot wire
is considered stock exclusion and so if
we did fence a stock uh fencing upgrade
that's um that is with the discretion of
the fund
uh or or to cut and pace course
it's just a question of if we think that
that's how the funding should be spent
yeah carrying on from chris's comments
with the fencing for uh
using money out of the out of the system
for fencing because i'm still very
worried about that
because what what are we going to do if
he decide he just the fan the leasy
farmer decides
that his standard of fencing is all he's
going to pay for
and we say well that's inadequate i mean
i i'd like to see a recommendation
recommendation go in here that this does
not proceed unless the fencing is fenced
to our
standard our satisfaction and and i
don't know how you
connect sorry
yeah well in a minute yeah because i
mean you know um sandra's just
alluded to the fact that this farm isn't
a hell of a good at um keeping stock out
of race
so it's not it's not a it's not a gold
standard farm by the sound of it in
terms of
fencing stock out of waterways was well
out of so it's the same problem
so um yeah we've got to be very careful
or
or i won't i won't i won't support the
planting until i'm happy that the
fencing is adequate
so if you look at the table on page 15
you mention about saving money with
potentially some
community input which which i really
support however i just wonder it's on a
very main road
and we've had issues in the past with
traffic management using community
volunteers on main roads
has that been considered so i should
have mentioned
that i have discussed the idea with the
landowner
and lisey and we've come to the
resolution that's probably not the best
to have a community planting event
so just yeah with with
that was after that so i had some
initial discussions but we we had
further discussions and yeah so it was i
should have sorry that's apologies i
should have mentioned that um
so is traffic management included in
this course
uh the traffic management for the
contractor
no so there's no traffic it's accessed
from
from the farm side there's no planting
along the road side of lehman's road
it's only one side of planting
yeah so traffic management's not
required
why isn't community planting possible
it's another issue of health and safety
on the farm yeah
and and the time they were concerned it
would take them time to organize the
community planting event and so i yeah
so i was offering my time but i can
understand it would take some effort
from them
their behalf as well i guess it's
important to note that this is not our
land if this was a piece of council and
we'd have staff resources and we'd have
time and other budgets that we could use
to enable the community to be able to
actually
get some benefit and empowerment and
ownership of areas like this but often
when you talk to
to farmers they um you know they take
health and safety very seriously but
they also understand
um the time constraints um and the
the cost that comes with those health
and safety so um it's a negotiation you
know to get to a point where you can
even give money i know it sounds strange
you're giving money to someone to do
something positive on their farm
but often that's a long negotiation to
even get to that point to try and get
stock out and to get the
real biodiversity and water quality
benefits that we're trying to get so
you know we only want to push so hard in
terms of getting them to
um to do certain things so it may be
that where we're looking at fencing and
gauss that might be something which
um we can ask them to do but it might be
something that this fund has to go a
little bit towards paying for as well
so could i just ask if something's
fundamental and the report changes like
that
that that is brought to our attention
when people speak to their reports
that's a fair point thank you
become d and the new c reads
that the the the scheme proceeds on the
contingent
that the fencing is uh
done to council satisfaction
prior to any planting
well we'll come back to the committee
and we'll look at a we'll look at what
what the farmer is
know as well proposing the satisfaction
um the the the project um what did i say
i can't remember what i said
the the the the the project proceeding
is contingent upon uh the fencing being
adequate to council satisfaction
prior to planting do you want me to to
add
well no i didn't want to dictate how
they actually fence it but
well there's the council staff
satisfaction you
you know what we've said it's got to be
wire it's got to be over
at least a meter high and it's got to
have hot a hot element
if you were just to add to the end of
the um to ensure
stock exclusion then yeah okay we'll
make it out we'll make sure it's
adequate for the purpose
specifically of exclusion excluding
okay
oh
madam chair actually it doesn't because
all that was happening was the movie was
accepting
what what they'll put forward in the
motion it wasn't amendment no no no
sandra didn't get a second
you should
existence of others here i just want to
add
um that i think um i would like a
signage on both plantings
to the effect that the southbrook
headwater spring protection planting
has been funded by the cam river
rehabilitation fund
and i would like that on that corner
here
and up at the gumtree spring
to acknowledge that this is in fact
publicly
funding a private
gain but also a wider public gain
thank you so where do we go from here
could incorporate that to the original
motion which might make it tidier
than debating amendment by amendment but
if um
if that was the case but that's up to
the mover if he's happy to in the chair
to accept it
yeah because we we before you arrive we
debated the whole fencing thing in quite
quite detail so we i don't think i don't
want to add any more debate
no no do you wish
yeah i want i want well as an
as an addition another it can be another
recommendation that is actually signage
put here
consideration would be the cost you know
those signs of looking at the ones we
put on the river you're looking at three
hundred bucks each
for two scientists another six hundred
dollars
and then the second and then if you wish
to place an amendment at that point
uh that's where there's the opportunity
providing you've got a second up
thank you it's it's all right people i'm
perfectly comfortable with this
it's actually following standing all
this counselor thank you
yes thank you thank you everybody um
councillor blackie would you like to
speak to no i have nothing to add madam
chair
thank you councillor yeah i think they
um
it's very very important for us to have
decent fencing to
protect the money we put public money
into the planting
so i think that's imperative to be done
and by the looks of the
existing uh fencing that is not adequate
um to um suffice so um
i'm quite comfortable um as long as what
um
council blacky was saying if the fencing
gets um to a decent standard
to keep the stock out of it um long term
and i think it'd be a good enhancement
for the area
thank you any other further
contributions
all right i'll put that
am i i'll thank you well i'll um put an
another recommendation um
in addition that um that signage to the
effect that this is a
um this planting spring protection
planting
is funded by the cam river
rehabilitation fund and
a sign placed doesn't have to be an
expensive one but
i think it is really important that the
public
um the public funding of this
thank you
yes well a sign put on both plantings
and ask for a seconder thank you we've
already got okay
thank you um yes so i think it's really
important this is a first
for this fund to fi to put money
into essentially pri private land
but with and certainly with a private
benefit there's no denying
but a wider public benefit that this
really important um uh spring head
of is more than one spring he'd been
protected here
is protected and enhanced by not just
the fencing that the
landowner has been required by law to
put in but
enhanced by native planting and adding
biodiversity
contribution to the general landscape
council banner
we've talked about how important the
education
is in this aspect i'm sure that staff
can come up with an option that's
not too expensive and i'm sure that they
can come up with something that's
appropriate for the area but you know if
this council is always asked what are we
doing in biodiversity what are we doing
in
and actually sustainability and
protecting our waterways
this is something we are doing um
through the the cam enhancement fund
so i really think it's absolutely
critical that we highlight that
and that that should then also then
encourage people who may want to say oh
actually what is the cam river
enhancement fund it could
actually give us some publicity we
probably should go and have an opening
once we're there because the whole point
is getting this into the public eye
so they take care of their rivers on
their private land
you look i want to reiterate that um we
just got a
a double a rating for our council which
uh most of us were critical on the
of the communications around that and
singing our praises
were asked through every ltp about
public-private partnerships
we're asked every time through our local
plans ltps and things about what we're
doing about sustainability
climate change all of those other things
and unless we start to look after
ourselves and these people that we're
trying to encourage to do the right
thing
then it will never happen and you know
contrary to how i'm not too worried
about
a a reasonable cost i don't mean a high
cost for signage
but a reasonable cost because if you're
going to put signers there it has to be
visible and it has to sing the praises
of both parties
and where we're going and what we're
doing with with this committee i mean we
thought at the start of this election
that this committee was well worth
setting up
now we're here we're doing it and it's
it's underway
so why shouldn't we be saying to people
this is what's happening with your
public money
to make sure that you have a better life
for your grandchildren
i've got um two ways of thinking on this
one
it's really good to put a sign up the
second way is at the thin
edge of the wedge when other farmers now
when they see that saying
exactly like councillor bunny was saying
before we want
our corners planted as well and um
you know they it's a
it's a type of thing um they may not
realize the council's paid for it and
all that drama
which is maybe uh i don't know if it's a
good thing or a bad thing
but it could um open the floodgates for
other people saying well we want our
areas done
and you pay for that area why aren't you
going to pay for my area
so so enjoying the queue exactly
and so i've got reservations whether
it's a good thing or a bad thing
i just don't know
it always sounds nicer when you say it
but you know it's just meanings
um yeah paul i hear what you're saying
with with
the signage but then again
this fund has 25 000 per year plus
chris brown has also indicated that
there may be
some other possible sources of funding
that can be applied for
and i think that raising
the visibility of these projects might
actually it is a thin edge of the wedge
but that's not necessarily a bad thing
because
for farmers to see oh oh he's excluding
the the stock from oh and planting oh
another one of those planting
projects oh actually that's a really
good thing and and
it looks really great it looks good in
the public eye the perception of farming
and whatnot it's good for the
environment
i can get some help with this and um
you know it i don't think that it's
necessarily a negative
if if it brings it into the the public
mind
and also the minds of of the landowners
that that it's a possibility
and we might actually get um
a bit more leverage on projects like
this with there being more knowledge of
their existence
so i don't think signs are bad but i
would like to
i wouldn't like to see the signage to be
you know large inexpensive and intrusive
because that's littering the
the countryside with signs so but i
think a little bit of
recognition as to how the projects
came to be is not necessarily a bad
thing so i'll support this
um a sign up acknowledging um the
public funding of this protection work
all those in favor please say against
declare it carried thank you and now we
um
a substantial motion and that's already
sorry
yes go ahead i've got no idea what i'm
doing
yes excellent look i just um
i suppose and it came out in the last
debate
for me even though we have to look after
the public person make sure
that we're watching what we're doing
with with funding for me this is not
about the funding
it's actually about the principle of
what we're trying to do here
and i mean i can remember sitting around
a table six or seven years ago
and all i got at the ltp was we're
farmers we're not bad people you know
we're trying to do our best
you know and while there's an element of
that there's also the element of those
that aren't
and the idea is to bring this together
and make sure that we're all swimming
from the same water head
[Laughter]
and the money is actually really
secondary but if we don't tell people
what we're doing
then we won't get to the mouth of the
river
there we go again you see we just won't
get there and
we won't get there without sludge on us
put it that way um
so we need to make sure that the
principal
overstands any money that we're doing
it's our job as governors to make sure
that money is kept in
in check but that is a normal function
of what we do
but the principle of this is actually
the really outstanding thing that we
need to make sure that we achieve
and it is a private public private
partnership some people hate them some
people love them
some people have no idea what you're
talking about so that's our job to
educate people and make sure
that these things um all match up and
that
as we go along and it's it's
generational it's not in a five-minute
job that they understand what it is that
we're trying to do
and we need to as a council in my view
back to the signage is make sure
that we actually tell people what it is
we do
yeah um i bought up the signings but and
to give it a debate i said i was sitting
on the fence i actually think
it's a good idea for us to let people
know i
um it's a pattern
no no no no no um
and and i hope it does bring in a wee
bit of a
um a debate with people wanting to do
their
corners their properties and um enhance
the different areas and we've got a wee
bit more money left so we could possibly
start a second ball rolling and um
um doing that type of thing but we need
to
let the rest of the people if there is a
a big role on effect from this that we
aren't a bottomless pit with money for
it
and um just encourage other people to
follow
the council's um start of it no you know
i think it's
long term will be a good thing when it
gets going if we've got a decent fence
to keep that stock out of it
thank you people that's a cheering
yes yes excellent excellent um
yes i do support um this
the wider aspect of the planting and i i
very much welcome the um amendment
that we get fencing that we're
comfortable to our satisfaction because
i took these photos and when i
saw it i was a bit disappointed about
whether in fact it was going to be as
stock
proof as we did want it um
passing this farm every day i do see
that this
these paddocks are very really greys
they're quite small
so there's not much stock in there and
certainly
the gum tree one is a little wee um
triangular piece of land that if there's
any but um if there's cows in there it's
it's a few hours but the thing
particularly about
um signage here is that not only does it
demonstrate
um public-private partnership the use of
the fund the first
real public use visible use of the fund
uh it is also um
going to give a signal to the public and
the farming public
that the council's put money into this
and it's also an incentive to this
farm particularly to keep up
um good maintenance practice this is
very very public and
the farmer is very very well aware of
the scrutiny that the farmers is under
and the fact that we've got a sign up
saying this public funds have gone into
there
i imagine that if there is any breach of
any fencing the maintenance starts to
slide that we'll hear about it and that
is all very welcome
and it's the only way we can guarantee
that
the public input to this
a project and 14 000
worth of plants is substantial that that
is actually recognised and publicized so
i'm very
keen that a um a very uh
a good sign but not an expensive sign is
put on both sides
anyone else want to no that's me isn't
it all right
now all right of reply to thank you
council blackie very briefly just
emphasizing the fencing thing at silver
stream reserve we've had over the last
five
years or so three episodes i can
remember where stock
twice cattle and once horse is broken
they can eat uh
six or eight of those animals can eat a
thousand bucks worth of trees an hour
if they're in there all night they could
wipe the entire project out overnight
the fencing thing is very critical
all right i'll put the recommendations
with the
additions and amendments all those in
favor please
say aye against
declare it carried and from this passing
of this i expect that
we will all expect that staff come back
with
um the revised fencing
program proposal to us it may be just an
email but we need to
be um understand what is the
well how our fencing requirement goes
with the landowner
and what comes back and if there is a
proposal
for instance to go into the fund to
upgrade the fence
this committee would surely want to
debate that
thank you well um
i think that's all we have as far as
we move on to questions item seven um
and i have none
urgent general business um i know that
none of that either
so um i can i will close this meeting at
whatever time that is oh hang on
10 25 we close the meeting and we now
move on to
some some briefings and sophie will take
[Music]
[Applause]
you